I've eaten a chapstick Wow I rolled up a
whole shaft segment like 27 so you just
go through phases curiosity good for you
yeah yeah hate a milk-bone not that long
ago really I was alone I mean it was a
weird choice yeah I had this idea that
it could be like like a meat biscotti
like something idiot with soup right it
didn't work out dinner was gross what's
up everybody welcome to stupid questions
I'm Krista Stefano aka Chrissy calamari
with me emmy blotnick
and she has got a half-hour special it's
on Comedy Central which is you knew that
cuz you're watching e train anyway ever
call you that you know I like it Oh
perfect this is good well the e train
it's a good train to solid train if you
could all of a sudden speak to dolphins
will be the first question you would ask
it I don't know how you say it in
dolphin but I'd want to ask him do you
wish you had hair yeah that's true
you don't Dolph it's one thing I learned
about them is they have sex for pleasure
what animals don't do that they also
rape each other that is true - yeah what
are you gonna do there's a dark side to
Dolphin it's true there are two sides to
every coin though if you could be a dog
I could just press a button you turn
into a dog who would you want to look
like a dock deal I'd want to be like
probably like a medium sized terrier and
I would want the rock to adopt me that's
awesome answer yeah you want those big
arms you'll save him what would I be I'd
be a bulldog that feels right just
because I always wanted to be British so
I felt a bit English full I'd be an
English Bulldog specifically I want to
be adopted by like by like the Queen I
want to be like a royal British bulldog
that's a beautiful yeah yeah yeah no
they've got royal staff to like clean
the wrinkles yeah my dumb face yeah
remove your crust
if you could stage the perfect heist
what would you rob who do you wanna be
you gonna get all right we're going to
the Metropolitan Museum we're taking all
the the giant stone dickless men yeah
and we're gonna move it into my house
it'll just be like 40 or 50 men with no
dicks and then would you want to put
dicks on them or they're just gonna
remain dickless dicks are in a separate
room and that's how I feel powerful
absolutely do you think when they make
you in stone is so is someone you wrong
it's gonna come and chop the dick off
here's what I hope doesn't happen I hope
one and if they do make me in stone they
don't make me with steroid dick because
steroids Nick it's a little dick the
foot is great okay oh my god you kidding
me it's from the back it's gonna look
unbelievable that's how I like men I
like the little dick in a big fat ass
samesies would you rather run out of
toilet paper in an airport bathroom or
fart loud enough that everyone could
hear you at a wedding see I feel like
the the no TP situation is like the
reality yeah it's just what have you
been in that we've all been in that
situation whereas I like to save my good
farts for my own wedding
please 100% invite me to your wedding if
you plan on doing that
yes literally I'll pay for my own point
I'll pay for everything I just want to
be there you've got it and if you got a
good one you can do it there too because
I'm holding in a sick one yeah then he
says anyone object I'll just rip it I'm
gonna put it on the registry one giant
fart but then it'll say that it's been
claimed Kristen hey yeah Chrissie
colonoscopy you have a good time you
show stupid questions and you know what
I want to get you a stupid gift now and
I was inspired by your joke which I love
fair you guys love to self potato pit so
look what I got you look at your own
self potato there you go it's got half a
mouth it's real human hair
I took pieces of your hair when you were
sleeping on but of course of the last
year ago and I made it so it's yeah I
have a gift for you too you do I do
oh my god hold my hold my daughter
I've never gotten again so this is
exciting here's a little purple hair
clip so your daughter can put her hair
back when she talks about your
cooking thank you very beautiful